- Seriously though, I can't believe
that like we've never met.
- I know
- And I lived in Nashville for like,
(audience laughing) for like 12 years.
- Like how have we never met?
- Cheers!
(audience clapping)
- So this is the best,
'cause I get what prayer
warriors are of where I'm from.
But like--
- Texas, my Texas girl!
- Texas exactly! And I
know a prayer warrior.
So you prayed so hard when
you heard Carrie Underwood,
she was thinking about having
y'all open for the tour right?
- Yes so word got out--
- Apparently you got a
line straight to God girl!
- Girl let me tell you.
- He was fed up with us by
the time we got the tour.
- We had this kinda crazy couple of years.
We were with a record company for a while
and then they just out
of nowhere shut down
while we were making our second record.
So we were kind of in this like,
crazy limbo.
We were on this huge peak of our career
and then just like crazy just,
like this.
So we started rebuilding
and just like pushing forward and forward.
And so word got out at our label
that we were on like the list.
And so Tay and I,
we had all of Texas and Oklahoma praying,
I was like Grandma, every single day.
Before every single show we
would sit in the back lounge
and we'd say God please, please, please
put us on the Carrie
Underwood tour please!
And he was finally like,
like when I talk about God,
it's like Octavia Spencer,
like that's kinda my vibe.
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Mine's more of Morgan Freeman.
- Yeah it has nothing to do with the movie
that he played God.
- So God was like,
Girls, I'm sick of y'all asking for this,
I'm just gon' give it to ya.
So here we go.
- I love it!